la troisième brigade d'assaut
ukrainienne entièrement composée de
volontaires partage son quotidien sur le
front
à proximité le commandement supervise
l'opération grâce à des images aériennes
et transmet ses ordres
c'est drone sont indispensables à
l'armée ukrainienne pour prévenir du
danger mais aussi pour mieux observer
l'ennemi au milieu de cette forêt quel
ciné avant de l'attaquer
loin des tractations diplomatiques en
cours à Washington sur le terrain les
combats continuent de jour comme de nuit
ce soldat blessé à la jambe est évacué
en urgence sa brigade a été prise pour
cible
il y a une attaque dans notre tranchée
un mec qui est mort dans mes bras
ça n'en vaut pas la peine ça ne vaut pas
toutes les vies perdues mais il n'y a
pas d'autres moyens
c'est pourquoi on demande plus d'aide en
véhicule et en arme
la brigade combat sans interruption
depuis janvier ces soldats avancent dans
un décor d'enfer entre arbres calcinés
terre brûlée et maisonnette en ruine le
village d'andréfa est entièrement
détruit mais désormais est reconquis par
l'Ukraine
nous sommes le 16 septembre la troisième
brigade d'assaut à entièrement pris le
contrôle du village d'endrifta gloire à
la nation morose ennemis
cette forêt tout repoussera
selon la brigade la libération dendrift
k offre des percées pour se rendre à
darkmouth sous contrôle russe est situé
à 15 km d'ici la ville reste l'un des
objectifs prioritaires de la
contre-offensive ukrainienne lancé cet
été